in the background
many of us are terrified of so much
disgrace illness sacking our mortality
the suffering and death of loved ones
when these fears come up were often
encouraged out of kindness to think of
the best case scenarios
it's a well-meaning move but it also
unintentionally leaves our fears to
fester they fill us with unnamed dread
and sometimes Lewton far larger than
they should so an opposite move on
display here involves looking our
anxieties directly in the eye
refusing to be cowed by them and
examining them in exhaustive detail so
as to drain them of their debilitating
power doing so is liable to bring us to
an important realization we could cope
even if the worst came to the worst what
follows are some invitations to meditate
on scary things not in order to depress
us but to lend us a buoyant optimistic
sense of our resilience and adaptability
the worst came to the worst I would
learn I had far fewer friends but the
ones that remained would be the true
ones the ones who could see past my
ruined social status to the genuine me
beneath if the worst came to the worst
it would no longer be an option to
follow the safe respectable prestigious
path with far less left to lose I would
at last be granted the opportunity to
explore the riskier yet more fulfilling
occupations
I had always somewhere hankered fall but
been too socially anxious to try
I'm taking a picture they'll be putting
you away soon if the worst came to the
worst I would learn to measure my
self-worth by my own standards rather
than the whims and applause of the crown
I would grow a sense of self independent
of the verdicts of others if the worst
came to the worst I would look with new
admiration and humility at the unhurried
calm natural stoicism and resilience of
animals if the worst came to the worst I
would learn to contemplate my sorrows
from the vantage point of a distant
nebula and would recognize my life as
the petty and insignificant thing it
truly is and always wants if the worst
came to the worst I would develop
appropriate gratitude for every
apparently minor thing and every day
that unfolded without further
catastrophe would be recognized as the
blessing it truly is if the worst came
to the worst I would understand that
life was not something that could ever
be molded into a wholly flawless and
error-free entity but isn't always
imperfect necessarily won't he cobbled
together construction full of marks and
blemishes which nevertheless possess
their own beauty and dignity
oh what a neglected cheerless place to
bring you to know if the worst came to
the worst I would learn to distinguish
between what's really serious and worth
lamenting and what is only ever a
passing nuisance I would in so many
situations be infinitely karma if the
worst came to the worst my failure would
embolden others to share stories of
their own sadness confusion and
humiliation and we would together face
up to the suffering we so often
currently unfairly endure alone if the
worst came to the worst I would see that
the struggle for fame money and success
was only ever a doomed attempt to
compensate for an unconditional love
that was longed for but denied in
childhood
[Music]
worldly craving would give way to
melancholy and mourning if the worst
came to the worst I'd cease to be so
scared of looking within and might
perhaps one day give psychotherapy ago
if the worst came to the worst I would
play the saddest songs that have been
waiting in the wings for me all this
time if the worst came to the worst
truly the worst then all the rage grief
anxiety and fear would be at an end and
we would at last as the prayers so
beautifully put it be at peace our
cheerful despair badge serves as an
elegant reminder of the art of cheerful
despair during hard times click on the
link on screen now to find out more if
you enjoyed this film be sure to
subscribe to our Channel and turn on
notifications